WILLIAM HAS BEEN COVERING THE
CARAVAN FOR SEVERAL WEEKS, DOING
AN AMAZING JOB.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO COVER
THIS UNTIL THE THREAT IS OVER
AND SITUATION IS DEALT WITH,
WHICH WILL LIKELY BE MANY
MONTHS.
WHY IS CNN SAYING IT FADED FROM
THE NEWS AND THAT OBAMA
PREDICTED IT WOULD HAPPEN?
HE IS ON THE BORDER IN TIJUANA
TONIGHT.
ENRIQUE, I WANT TO START WITH
YOU BECAUSE YOU HEARD WILLIAM'S
REPORT.
HE'S BEEN WITH THE CARAVAN FOR
WEEKS, COVERING IT, ESPECIALLY
IN TIJUANA.
THE PEOPLE OF TIJUANA DON'T WANT
THIS.
WE HAVE REPORTS THAT CHILDREN
AND WOMEN HAVE DISAPPEARED FROM
ONE OF THE CARAVANS, PERHAPS
KIDNAPPED BY HUMAN TRAFFICKERS.
THAT NEWS FROM A "USA TODAY"
PIECE FROM YESTERDAY.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS HERE?
I MEAN, THIS SEEMS VERY, VERY
CONCERNING.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION, LAURA, PART OF
THE COMMUNITY, PART OF LOCAL
RESIDENTS HERE IN TIJUANA HAVE
CRITICIZED THE PRESENCE OF THE
MIGRANT CARAVAN, BUT THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY HAVE SHOWN
A COMPASSIONATE AND HUMANITARIAN
REACTION.
SO IT'S NOT ALL OF TIJUANA.
SOME PEOPLE IN TIJUANA DON'T
WANT THEM HERE, BUT I WOULD SAY
THE MAJORITY HAVE SHOWN
COMPASSION AND EMPATHY.
ON THE OTHER HAND, ABOUT THE
ALLEGED DISAPPEARANCE OF A LARGE
GROUP OF MIGRANTS, IT JUST GOES
TO SHOW YOU THE DIFFICULT
CONDITIONS, THE INCREDIBLE
VIOLENCE THAT THEY FACE IN THEIR
JOURNEY THROUGH MEXICO TOWARDS
THE U.S. BORDER.
THE CARAVAN IS NOT JUST ONE
THING.
IT HAS MANY REALITIES.
IT HAS THOUSANDS OF DIFFERENT
STORIES.
SO IT'S NOT VERY CAREFUL TO
FRAME THE DEBATE IN ABSOLUTE.
>> Laura: BUT THAT'S WHY
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID BACK IN
2014, DO NOT BRING YOUR
CHILDREN.
THE TREK IS DANGEROUS.
DO NOT BRING THEM.
HE SAID, BECAUSE YOU WILL NOT BE
ALLOWED TO STAY.
OF COURSE, MOST OF THEM WERE
ANN COULTER, YOU REMEMBER THAT.
THESE ARE NOW 100 CHILDREN AND
WOMEN WHO WERE GONE.
AND THIS IS A REPORT FROM
ARTURO.
HE IS ON VERY GOOD AUTHORITY,
VERY GOOD REPORTING.
SO THIS MAGNATE IN THE UNITED
STATES OF PREVIOUSLY AT LEAST
CATCH AND RELEASE.
THEY ARE PUTTING PEOPLE'S LIVES
IN DANGER, ARE THEY NOT?
>> YES.
YES, THEY ARE.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALREADY
SIGNED AND EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THIS WAS OBVIOUSLY A CAMPAIGN
STUNT.
THEY HOPED THE CARAVAN WOULD
ARRIVE ON AMERICA'S BORDER JUST
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS TO
SHOW THAT NOT ONLY DO WE NOT
HAVE A WALL, BUT TRUMP CAN'T
STOP THEM.
HERE YOU HAVE IS THIS HUGE
INVASION COMING IN.
THEY PLANNED THIS AS A CAMPAIGN
STUNT, BUT THEN TRUMP TOOK THEM
UP ON IT, CALLED THEIR BLUFF,
SAID THEY'RE SENDING TROOPS TO
THE BORDER.
AND SUDDENLY OBAMA IS TALKING
ABOUT IT.
WHAT DID HE CALL IT, THE MYTH OF
THE CARAVAN?
WELL, IT'S STILL COMING.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO DID ARRANGE
THIS, COUNTRIES WITHOUT BORDERS
IN SPANISH, THEY ARE SETTING UP
THESE WOMEN AND CHILDREN TO BE
RAPED, MURDERED, SOLD TO OTHER
PEOPLE.
THEY OUGHT TO BE PROSECUTED FOR
INCITING AND ENCOURAGING HUMAN
SMUGGLING.
WE HAVE LAWS ON THE BOOKS ABOUT
THIS.
THEY SET THIS IN MOTION.
I DON'T WANT ALL OF LATIN
AMERICA MOVING TO OUR COUNTRY,
BUT I DON'T WANT THEM BEING
MURDERED AND RAPED ALONG THE
WAY.
LEFTISTS DON'T CARE.